a senior manager at amazon who is suing
the e-commerce giant for racial
discrimination
is speaking exclusively to cbs this
morning in her first television
interview
charlotte newman filed a federal lawsuit
against amazon and
two managers claiming she was underpaid
stereotyped
sexually harassed and sexually assaulted
newman alleges the discrimination began
during her hiring process in 2017
when she says she was offered a job
below the level
and pay she had applied for it's a
practice known as down leveling
cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller sat down with the amazon
web services
senior manager there's a problem with
the culture and with practices
charlotte newman says she's speaking out
now because she thinks it's time for a
change in amazon
it's time for amazon to act with the
same obsession internally with the same
rigor that we approach
our businesses and our customers in the
lawsuit
newman who's still employed by amazon
alleges the company pays her less
than people with similar experience she
says she's also been the victim of
stereotypical
racial tropes in one instance she says a
co-worker told her
she looked like a gorilla and she says a
manager called her aggressive
too direct and just scary i'm not here
because
it's just about me as the vox reporting
demonstrates
there's a pattern of systemic
discrimination newman's lawsuit came
shortly
after vox's website recode published an
investigation
into treatment of black employees at
amazon
i think a lot of these issues have been
festering at the company
senior recode correspondent jason del
rey says
he spoke to 10 black employees who told
him
they face both direct and insidious bias
that harms their careers and personal
lives
there are some really awful experiences
relate to me
one comes to mind you know about a a
black employee who had
a manager from another team tell her
just sort of
unprompted that he's pretty sure his
ancestors had slaves at some point but
but he thinks that
they were treated well recode also
reported that internal amazon data shows
black corporate employees are promoted
less frequently
and rated more harshly by managers than
non-black
employees in response an amazon
spokesperson told us
we work hard to make amazon a company
where our black employees and people of
all backgrounds feel included
respected and want to grow their careers
and they do not tolerate discrimination
or harassment in any form
amazon needs to do more than just make
statements about black lives matter
and make statements about what they're
doing for black employees and other
employees of color
and have that actually show up in how
employees are being treated
newman says for her it went beyond
racial discrimination and
unfair pay in her lawsuit she says
management engaged in repeated sexual
harassment
including incidents of inappropriate
unwelcome touching and sexual assault
she says she was groped by a manager at
a work function
he put his hand on my thigh and began to
like rub and kind of caress my thigh
and move up my leg and
i froze and was
just completely embarrassed and just
stunned at like such a brazen act
you know all of the time spent ensuring
that
you know i'm coming into work and being
a professional
just to be sort of reduced to to that
was very difficult
the alleged incident happened in 2018
but newman says she did not report it
until last
year i think he understood the gravity
of what had happened in some ways
but i also think because he chose to put
his hands on me again
clearly you know he like to me he
demonstrated that he's a predator
what happened the second time i was
again at a work
like with colleagues this was at an off
site and i was getting ready to leave
and he grabbed my braids and
he made like an offhand comment about
like you can leave these here
why did you decide to stay at amazon
well i think all too often
the brunt of sexual harassment and
discrimination it falls on the victim
and i felt why should i be the one
to leave one of the biggest fastest
growing companies in the world
an amazon spokesperson told cbs news we
do not tolerate discrimination or
harassment of any kind
we immediately investigated ms newman's
sexual harassment claim
and fired her harasser they added we
also reviewed miss newman's
interview process leveling and
onboarding
and determined that she was properly
placed in her role at the company
can things get better at amazon for you
i hope they get better for all employees
as i was coming here today i was
thinking about a quote by coretta scott
king
it essentially says that struggle never
ends you
constantly fight for freedom and that
every generation essentially has to
do that that was our colleague michelle
miller reporting we do have a bit more
from amazon a spokesperson tells cbs
news the investigation into newman's
alleged sexual harassment resulted in
additional training requirements for
those in her reporting line
they are also investigating the new
allegations in her lawsuit they say
and they said they've set a number of
targets company-wide
commitments to diversity telling us
they've doubled representation of black
directors and vice presidents
last year and they've committed to do
the same in 2021
well let's hope they want to do the work
i say bravo to ms newman a for raising
the issues and b
for staying yeah we're staying because
that's how you're going to have change
you have to stay you have to speak up
and people have to hear you and she said
why should i be the one to leave exactly
exactly right it was very difficult
though to hear somebody at the company
say
you know my family had slaves or
whatever he said but they were treated
well i lost a little bit of hearing
after that
such an oxymoron